in the middle of the 19th century a
scientist stared into his microscope and
found staring back at him a vampire
like the creatures of Legend the
organism he saw was a shape-shifter
though not the kind whose body contorts
from something vaguely human into
something more like a bat no what he
found was an amoeba and it was in search
of something to sink its fangs into
foreign
the amoebas we are discussing today
belong to the order vampirellida which
holds two families the first is the
family Vampire relliday made up of
organisms known generally as Vampirella
and the second family is leptophria day
which holds essentially everything else
the left of fries we're looking at now
the arachnilla we opened the episode
with and a bunch of others now we're not
here today to navigate the complicated
taxonomic histories here though we want
to stay up front that while we're going
to be using the name vampire relids as a
convenient labeled the organisms who are
gathered under that umbrella have a
wider array of identities
Vampirella translates to Little Vampire
in Latin the name was first given to
members of the vampirellita order in
1865 by the Polish microbiologist Leon
chenkovsky who was very much inspired by
the vampires of lore when naming these
features when you think of vampires
perhaps you think of blood and
viciousness but the vampire Relic does
not want blood it wants cytoplasm and
yes it will be vicious to get what it
wants we know of about 50 species of
vampire relats scattered all around the
world some like ours live in Palms
living among filamentous algae and
desmonds others prefer Marine
environments while some can be found in
soil but despite this range of
environments they share a very distinct
life cycle that revolves around feeding
the first stage of life is the
trophozoite though in the past it's also
been known as the swarmer stage that's
because this is the time of the vampire
Ellen's life when it is on the move or
perhaps more accurately when it is on
the hunt moving with one purpose to find
food luckily for them but not for their
prey vampirellids have an expansive
palate they've been known to consume
everything from green algae to diatoms
to yeast to rotor for eggs with such a
wide menu to choose from Vampire relics
wield a number of different strategies
to capture their prey Each of which
manages to sound a little bit creepier
than the last
the least unsettling of all is free
capture a method of eating that's quite
common throughout the microcosmos the
vampire Relic captures their food and
then swallows them up in a food vacuole
that can break down the prey to extract
the nutrients they need it doesn't sound
like a pleasant thing to go through as
prey but it's a method of eating that is
at least familiar the next method though
is a little more disconcerting starting
with the name Colony Invasion with this
strategy the vampire relid Finds Its way
into algae colonies digging past the
gelatinous Matrix that holds them
together so that it can be surrounded by
its prey not only does the vampire relat
effectively take up residence in a
buffet it is able to hide out in that
Colony as well staying out of sight from
other predators that might want to come
after it it turns its prey into a shield
and a restaurant all at once
vampirellids can also consume their prey
through something called protoplast
extraction which perhaps sounds more
mundane than it actually is this is the
feeding strategy behind the vampire
relic's name the action that chinkowsky
and plenty of other scientists have
witnessed and documented despite the
impact of this method on the scientific
imagination we don't actually know fully
how it works it's controlled by the
vampire relids pseudopodia these long
filaments that Branch out from its body
and the vampirellid Begins by poking or
dissolving holes in their prey from
there they then use two feeding
pseudopodia to dig into the prey cell to
act like straws or you might say like
vampire fangs and there's actually one
last vampire relative approach to dining
though it is quite rare it's called prey
infiltration and it's kind of like
getting to the fourth entry in a horror
movie series and realizing every
frightening image you're about to see is
actually like a remix of previous
Terrors taken to their most gruesome end
prey infiltration begins similarly to
protoplast extraction with the
vampirellid puncturing its prey but then
it shifts into something more like
Colony Invasion except instead of
invading The Colony the vampirellid
invades the body of its prey to feed
from within imagine Dracula not just
sucking blood from your neck but somehow
invading your body through holes left by
his fangs and then consuming your blood
from within or maybe don't imagine that
perhaps we've taken the metaphor a
little too far
however the vampire Ellen chooses to eat
the next stage of its life is the same
it will turn from a trophozoite to a
cyst retracting those long filamentous
extensions Inward and forming a cell
wall around itself that might even
attach to surfaces around the organism
we've seen plenty of cysts in the
microcosmos Each of which iterates on
some version of the same Theory when an
organism finds itself in dire
environmental circumstances it holds up
an assist where it winds down its
metabolism and rests waiting for things
to clear up so that it can emerge and
survive and while vampirellids can form
that kind of resting cyst what we're
watching now is actually a very
different kind of state this is a
vampire relid in a digestive cyst it
hasn't shut off its metabolism quite the
opposite the whole point of the
digestive cyst is to give the
vampirellid time to break down its meals
some species will even change color
turning red or yellow or some other
color as its body responds to the
changes brought on by the vampire relics
meal if we were to turn back to popular
images of vampires perhaps this is the
vampire relats coffin a place for it to
rest while it processes the cytoplasmic
sips it took from the body of another
organism except even then the stories we
tell of vampires failed to capture all
of the Twisted Tangles of the vampire
relin's life because when the
vampirellet is done digesting it does
two things first it emerges from its
cyst punching holes in the walls it used
to encase itself and cycling back into
its trophozoite state but sometimes more
than one trophozilite emerges because
while the vampirellid was in the cyst it
might have divided once twice maybe even
more times and second the vampirellid
gets rid of its undigested food remains
leaving behind what scientists have
described as numerous Brown particles
foreign
so again if we're trying to put this in
Vampire terms imagine a vampire ready to
emerge from its coffin at night it's
digested its meals and is ready to hunt
but first the vampire needs to clone
itself a few times and then with its
bloodthirsty clones our vampire will
proceed to punch holes in its coffin
until they can climb out and then before
they get ready to hunt they do have to
poop
when jenkovsky decided to give the
Vampirella to their name did he imagine
taking the metaphor this far we don't
know but we hope so we hope that
somewhere out there are the ghosts of a
19th century conversation between
biologists perhaps arguing the merits of
comparing these tiny organisms to a
legendary figure and perhaps they
settled on understanding that sometimes
the only way to describe the Fantastical
worlds we see is to turn to the
Fantastical creatures we imagine and to
wonder what other monsters
foreign foreign
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us
the people on the screen right now they
are our patreon patrons who allow us to
dive deeper and deeper into our really
wonderful and fascinating world a world
that we all get to occupy together even
if we don't know of all the organisms we
are occupying it with but that's a shame
we should know about them and that's why
we're here so if you want to help us
make this stuff you can go to
patreon.com journey to micro and have
your name be one of the names on this
screen if you want to see more from our
master of microscopes James Weiss you
can check out jam and germs on Instagram
and if you want to see more from us I
bet you there's a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
[Music]
thank you